celebrations in the Guatemalan Capital
supporters of the center-left
anti-corruption candidate Bernardo
Arevalo cheering his Landslide victory
over former first lady Sandra Torres
we are out celebrating the seed we
planted with our vote hoping it will
flourish
[Music]
fellow seen by many as a political
Outsider managed to shake up Guatemala's
political landscape one of the biggest
electoral surprises in recent memory
today Guatemalans have hope we are
celebrating the return of the feeling of
Hope in the streets of our country
eight thousand electoral observers were
deployed in Guatemala to oversee the
election following a controversial
campaign season marred by concerns about
democracy here being threatened
this is possibly the most important
election that we've had in the last 38
years because we've had the chance to
stop the backsliding that we've
experienced in the last three years and
closed the door on the threat of
authoritarianism
arevalo's victory in Sunday's election
is seen as the culmination of widespread
discontent over worsening crime
corruption and economic stagnation
issues that some analysts say have no
easy solution the problem with that
evalu is expectations are really high
but problems are really hard to fix
he also fears there could soon be
attempts by the opposition to undermine
arevalo's victory
absolutely ecstatic crowd here in
Guatemala
malice none of that seems to matter
right now this is a moment of
Celebration
Guatemala City
foreign